HOW TO TREAT MARIJUANA POTION.
EIGHT STATES ALLOW RECREATIONAL
USE OF MARIJUANA AND A MAJORITY
ALLOW ITS USE FOR MEDICAL
PURPOSES.
TONIGHT WE WRAP UP OUR 3-PART
SERIES ON THE FUTURE OF AMERICAN
FARMING.
LAST NIGHT WE TOLD YOU HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS TO CONTINUE THE
GENERATIONS LONG TRADITION OF
THE FAMILY FARM BECAUSE OF
FACTORS INCLUDING DIFFICULT
TRADE POLICIES WITH NATIONS SUCH
AS CHINA AND THE POSSIBILITIES
OF MORE TARIFFS.
TONIGHT, A BIT OF OPTIMISM.
DOUG TELLS US THERE IS A NEW
GENERATION OF FARMERS IN AMERICA
COMING FROM AN UNLIKELY PLACE:
BIG CITIES.
>> THAT SHOWS HOW FULL THEY ARE.
>> SOME MIGHT THINK CJ IS
RISKING TOO MUCH CONSIDERING THE
DELINING FORTUNE OF THE AMERICAN
FAMILY FARM.
BUT HE IS SELLING THE BEEF,
POULTRY AND EGGS HE RAISES ON
LAND HIS ANCESTORS BUILT.
>> WE GOT INTO PRODUCING IT.
WE WERE FORTUNATE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL WITH THE TIMING.
>> CJ IS AT THE FOREFRONT OF A
RENAISSANCE IN SMALL TARMING.
-- FARMING.
HE HAS A SECOND JOB WITH A D.C.
FIRE
FIR
FIREFIGHTER.
>> I LOVE IT AND COMING HOME TO
THE COUNTRY.
>> THOUSANDS OF OTHERS ARE
RETURNING TO THE LAND.
COMBINING OLD-SCHOOL FARMING
WITH 21st CENTURY MARKETING.
>> THEY ARE STARTING A BUSINESS
SELLING DIRECT AT A FARMER'S
MARKET OR SUBSCRIPTIONS.
>> A LOBBIEST SHOULD KNOW.
IN 2 WEEKS HE IS LEAVING THE
WASHINGTON RAT RACE TO RETURN TO
HIS FAMILY FARM IN NEW HAMPSHIRE
TO PRAISE BEEF TO CAPITALIZE ON
THE TREND TO GROW AND EAT
LOCALLY.
>> WE ALL USED TO EAT LOCAL
FOOD.
OUR DIETS WERE CHANGED BY WHAT
WAS IN SEASON NEAR US.
WE HAD REGIONAL FOODS.
>> CONGRESS IS INTENT ON
EXPANDING OPPORTUNITIES.
ONE BILL WOULD REMOVE HEMP FROM
THE CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES ACT.
WITH ITS SOIL REPLENISHES
QUALITIES AND USING IN FABRIC
AND FOOD AND ANTI-SEIZURE OILS
MANY ARE CONVINCED IT'S A
REPLACEMENT.
>> IT COULD RE-ENERGIZE
COMMUNITIES.
>> SOME BELIEVE CONGRESS IS NOT
DOING ENOUGH.
NOTING THE FARM BILL NEEDS MORE
INCENTIVES TO ATTRACT YOUNG
FARMERS TO THIS RISK-FILLED
ORGANIZATION.
97% OF FARMS ARE RUN BY FAMILIES